another project that I thought was just
outstanding was a pure air project and
the reason is because the kinds of solar
power that you need the level of energy
that you need the waters that you need
to just drive a fan to be able to
evacuate smoke out of the tent is
relatively low and you know solar panels
are having a hard time powering our
cities but they're great for powering
accessories they're really not bad for
powering small things like a fan the
same time more and more reports are
coming out about ultrafine particles and
how ultrafine particles especially for
cooking when they lodging themselves
deep in your lungs they are what cause
asthma long-term and so literally people
at home cooking with let's say frying
and chicken they do that ultrafine
particles at least in the air they stay
tuned four five six hours even if you'll
be a winner if it takes five or six
hours because the particles to sell down
so for those five or six hours your kids
are breathing air that's literally
putting ultrafine particles deep in
their lungs and so this idea that you
take really simple the exciting modern
technology like solar power and simple
van and add that to a cooking system so
that the air can stay cleaner to me
that's fantastic what's more we can test
it so that's exciting because we can
actually quantitatively tell are we
making a real difference is there enough
of a difference to affect the health of
the kids who happen to be sleeping
living in that test